I see all the time those stories where people are like,
oh, we were married for all these years,
we broke up,
got divorced,
and then 15 years later we got remarried again.
I do not ever see that happening in my situation. Ever.
I don't believe in going in the past. I don't.
I don't give a fuck what common thread we have together.
We tried it,
it didn't work.
I don't know.
No. Also for the confusion it would potentially cause
my children.
I would never wanna have to put them through that twice.
Do you know what I mean?
So like, we were married,
we had kids,
we had a family,
we broke up,
everybody healed from that.
To then get back together.
At the risk of
then what if you break up again?
Putting your kids through all that again?
No, it's done.
Enclosed. We're done,
done, done, done.
I hope one day we can be friends in cordial.
Cause that would just be easy
since we literally have children in common.
But as far as
ever being in a relationship with that person again,
literally never.
Over my fucking dead body.